[Música]
empezamos nuestro segmento especial de
aquí a américa camino a la casa blanca
el espacio para revisar los temas clave
de esta contienda entre el presidente de
donald trump y el candidato demócrata
joe biden de cara a las elecciones del 3
de noviembre hoy vamos a hablar del
nuevo campo de batalla la corte suprema
tras la muerte de la jueza ruth báder
ginsburg la magistrada y como de la
lucha por la igualdad femenina en eeuu
murió el 18 de septiembre a riviera un
icono pop y al fallecer fue honrada por
miles de personas en la sede de la corte
suprema en washington su fallecimiento
abrió una vacante en la corte suprema de
justicia en pleno año electoral el
debate se centra en si esa nominación
que corresponde al presidente debería
hacerse antes o después de las
elecciones pues sería la tercera
nominación de trump lo que consolidaría
la tendencia conservadora de la corte
que actualmente está compuesta por cinco
jueces conservadores tres nominados por
george w.bush y dos por trump y tres
liberales
uno de bill clinton y dos de barack
obama en 2016 en un escenario similar
cuando murió el juez antoñín scalia el
presidente era un demócrata barack obama
quien insistía en la urgencia de la
nominación en la constitución es
bastante clara sobre lo que se supone
que debe suceder ahora cuando eres rey
que cuando hay una vacante en la corte
suprema- el presidente de eeuu debe
nominar a alguien mientras que el por
entonces precandidato republicano a la
presidencia de donald trump pedía que se
dilatara el proceso yo creo que depende
de mitch mcconnell y de todos los demás
detenerlo se llama demora demora demora
vamos a la capital estadounidense para
hablar con nuestra corresponsal diana
castañeda diana cuéntanos cuál es el
legado de ruth báder ginsburg hola que
tal pues deja un gran legado en materia
de la protección de los derechos de
minorías y sobre todo la igualdad en
materia de derechos para las mujeres no
solamente abogo por la separación del
estado y de la iglesia también por los
derechos
es uno de los casos que es más recordado
por ejemplo es del instituto militar de
virginia en donde su decisión fue
crucial para que se permitiera que
mujeres cadetes ingresarán a este
instituto por primera vez en la historia
desde que fue fundado diana y qué
impacto tiene la nominación de un
conservador para ocupar su lugar pues
como veíamos ya actualmente la corte
está compuesta por cinco jueces
conservadores y tres liberales
bueno esta conformación de la corte será
fundamental porque va a marcar digamos
la línea de decisiones que puede tomar
el tribunal en las próximas décadas para
los eeuu frente a decisiones importantes
como lo ha hecho anteriormente con temas
como por ejemplo el aborto pero también
es fundamental justo ahora digamos por
esta presión que dicen los demócratas
tiene el presidente de donald trump este
afán para acelerar el proceso de
nominación de confirmación debido a las
elecciones presidenciales y es que
durante esta pandemia es posible que no
se conozcan quién será el presidente de
los eeuu el próximo noviembre 3 si se
tenga que llevar a los días después
contar esas votaciones esos votos que se
hicieron a través de correo y se podría
dar un escenario no está descartado es
sólo uno de los posibles escenarios de
que llegue a ocurrir algo como lo que
ocurrió en el año 2000 entre bush y al
gore que se llevó a un conteo a un
reconteo y al final terminó la corte
suprema- decidiendo quién era el
presidente cinco votos
favor y 4 en contra de bus y termina
siendo el presidente de los eeuu así que
será fundamental esta composición y caso
de que un escenario así también se
llegará y diana como interpretamos estos
cambios de discurso que veíamos también
respecto a 2016 tanto de los
republicanos como de los demócratas
sobre la nominación quien debería
hacerlo realmente según la constitución
bueno la constitución solamente
establece que es el presidente de los
eeuu el que debe nominar a un candidato
para que llegue a la corte suprema y que
es el senado el que el que debe dar esta
confirmación pero no establece
exactamente un parámetro de tiempo
y tampoco de casos excepcionales como si
está cercana a una votación a una
elección presidencial así que digamos
esa es la polémica que se ha generado en
el caso del presidente barack obama era
mitch mcconnell quien le decía que no
debía nominar alguien a la corte hasta
que no se realizarán las elecciones
presidenciales y que el pueblo debería
tener también decisión frente a este
tema y ahora es el mismo misma con el
quien debe llevar a cabo este proceso y
que dice que se debe decidir un juez
antes de que se realicen las elecciones
gracias diana castañeda corresponsal de
france 24 en washington por su
intervención en este segmento especial
de aquí américa camino a la casa blanca
los ustedes gracias por acompañarme en
esta emisión recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho de el coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]